guys I promise this is not an Oreo
milkshake this is indeed a black seed
ice cream milkshake first we're gonna
need some organic milk gotta get that
good stuff but then we also need some
ice cream gotta get that verge of black
seed oh I promised these black seeds
were virgins gotta get now that nature's
blends curing Ethiopian black seeds and
then we gotta get the whipped cream cuz
you already know we need that don't
forget we gotta blend it in the Magic
Bullet you already know so now what
we're gonna do is after removing all
this stuff it's get that organic milk
and you're gonna pour approximately I
don't know how much you just put some in
so that the thing gets filled up then
you're gonna open up that ice cream and
you're gonna break it off with your
hands make sure you use your right hand
because that's the right thing to do bro
and get all of it in there you know be
cheap we got to get that in there put
that virgin flaxseed oil in there I
promise guys this is the best part of
this milkshake you want to get give
generously give generously don't be
cheap all right
you mix it in there then you want to
just stir it up stir it all up in there
then you got to get that Ethiopian stuff
right there get that black seed and you
sprinkle approximately as much as you
want to do because you can never have
enough black seeds no no put some work
with some work all right have is enough
you cap that up and the blending process
guru all right open that up pour in your
cup generously gotta get the whipped
cream bro put that in there right now
listen this is the best part you gotta
garnish it with some black seed
sprinkles baby this is the best part
guys look how beautiful this looks this
looks like an Oreo milkshake but I
promise it's not and guess how it tastes
fantastic iris but I've gotta try this
black seed oil ice cream milkshake
before la comes in laughs if you ever
had any trouble with black Jesus just
make it so much easier to drink and
tolerate
you're getting the sweetness you
definitely do taste the Black Sea masala
but this is good guys try this recipe
out tell me to come section below how
you guys liked it tell me if there's
another recipe that you can use with
black seed oil let me know the palm
section below join me on this 30 days in
that challenge strong I'll catch you
next time